[Music]
hey guys for years fans have been
looking forward to the gambled a long
anticipated death match between
centering Gregor Clegane the Hound in
the mountain the show certainly seemed
to set it up in the season 7 finale when
they come confront in his much change
brother at the dragon bit centre said
remember me yeah you do you're even
uglier than I am now
what did they do to you doesn't matter
it's not how it ends for your brother
you know who's coming for you you've
always known fans theorized there's an
interesting detail this line hint that
it's not how it ends for your brother
you know who's coming for you earlier in
season 7 we saw the Hound look into the
flames and see a vision more precisely
and accurately then any Melisandre ever
read the scene made fans wonder how he
could be so good at that in first
attempt and led them to conclude that it
was not his first time reading fire fans
explained meant centre Clegane tells the
story of his burns he says that he was
playing with one of his brothers toys
without permission he says that his
brother became so angry that he pushed
his head into the fire now knowing what
we know about Gregor this is certainly
possible but there might be an even more
sensible explanation given what we've
seen now in the show centers saw his
brother's death in the fire and told him
about it
Gregor became enraged at the thought of
his death and so I pushed Center into
the fire he was reading fans claim this
makes all the following make more sense
by the Hound was able to so easily see
visions in the fire this season why says
confidently to his brother that he knows
who is coming for him why Gregor Clegane
had enough rage to push his brother into
the fire
interesting thought what's also
plausible is that the toy incident
happened but when Sanders head was in
the flames he also saw a vision as
opposed to his so division and then
Gregor pushed him in the combination
being burned and also seeing a vision
would be plenty to terrify the Hound
regard to fire for the rest of his life
similar to how various has been scared
of the Lord of light and fire reading
anyways this long-awaited confrontation
between senator hound and Gregor the
mountain gain will almost definitely go
down in season eight which has big
hinted multiple times by the actor who
plays the mountain to start he told the
fan that his favourites in the film
happens in season 8 the only seen to be
the mountains brutal defeat of Oberyn
Martell
vacancies inform must be the coup gamble
additionally bjornsen told Fox News that
season eight was the hardest season he
has ever done for game thrones he said
it was the most difficult like
physically and mentally for me as a
professional strongman the prospect of
season a testing Berenson physically
should raise an eyebrow might mountain
be part of an epic battle scene the
Creston crew have been breathless still
teasing for months or could they finally
see the long very throw down between the
mountain and his little brother the
hound it's also important to highlighted
burns on the mountain had a stunt double
for the first time in game turns is Nate
just lately Bjorn Singh's plane to
Mashable dead after seven season he's
finally going to have a stunt double for
the final season now game turns in
seasons past Bernsen did all the
mountain stands himself that comes as no
surprise because he's clearly built to
handle almost anything one would ask
what was beyond some filming in season a
that he could not do it himself perhaps
an epic fight scene clicking ball most
likely one of my most popular theory
says that Qyburn is not working for
Cersei but for various the theory oath
says that through Gregor cool game will
be of a huge importance in James
homicide over Cersei Lannister as the
mountain is in my opinion loyal towards
its creator Qyburn who is not served as
loyalists and who brought Baxter Gregor
to life only to act as his minion which
is part of a bigger plan o vengeance
otherwise it would not make any sense
for Qyburn to bring the mountain to life
who back in the third season almost
killed him just like it doesn't make any
sense for Qyburn to be loyal to the
Lannisters whose prisoner he was and not
the Starks who saved his life
it's all part of a bigger plan Avengers
already made an entire video in which I
explain why Qyburn is not loyal toward
Thursday
supported by a few hints and prove it is
going favorited the mountain stars is
closest and the only guard throughout
the previous few seasons will also
continue to be in the upcoming season as
well as leaked photos confirm is also
not loyal toward Cersei additionally the
mountain will play major role in Jaime's
homicide where Cersei which represent
arguably the greatest wasting game from
series even greater than Bolton same
phrase betrayal over Starks Cersei will
be betrayed by your three most trusted
people would be killed by her brother
but most justed advisor and by her most
trusted guard not only the de steering
with Jaime with the help of Qyburn in
the mountain will kill Cersei will be
one of the greatest wasting amateur
series
but it also seems that something the
showrunners would love to leave us the
touch of speechless again if you'd like
to check out all the evidence support
his great best make sure to check out my
previous videos anyways even if the
mountain which racers say on climbers
orders say helps Jamie or area or to
whomever to kill Cersei the mountains
still deserve sin he has to die sir
Gregory's betrayal research they would
be a good act but far from enough for
his brother Center cocaine and
eventually for us to forgive him all his
sins all the crimes that he has done
throughout his life the mountain who has
insatiable bloodlust that he releases
tracts of extreme violence has done more
than a few terrible things for his life
which he started doing since he was a
child he held his own siblings head into
a burning brazier only because his
younger brother played with a toy he
discarded as the mountain was growing he
was killing more and more innocent
people was raiding more and more
villages so it later be knighted by
prince rhaegar targaryen this honorable
man that the mountain is home always
liked honor only one year passed since
he was knighted by Rhaegar and still he
obeyed orders to kill the same princess
two children during Robert's rebellion
and brutally rate wreckers weifare upon
he killed her and ever since that event
is often referred to as timely in stirs
Mad Dog the head of House Clegane feared
throughout Westeros the mountain is
infamously this honorable man and even
if he is going to betrayed Cersei he
still deserves and he has to die and the
best way to see the mountains death will
be Inca gamble which seems more and more
likely to happen in the final season own
game turns the game ball image to beasts
to brothers the ham that the mountain
would meet and fight to death
constantly will not happen in the first
episodes of season 8 since the Hound is
sailing north with John Snow and Danny
what you can expect to see in the first
episodes of the final season of the cool
game brothers is the hunt reuniting with
the stark sisters one of which he
protected more than once back in King's
Landing and the other he learned many
life lesson says what was fighting in my
opinion Clegane Bowl is not questionable
it will happen at some point of the
final season probably in the very final
episode the outcome of that battle is
also very important and at the same time
very questionable at one end we have the
mountain whom Robb Stark is scribed as a
mad dog without strategic thought in his
head it's one of the best warriors at
the Seven Kingdoms currently hence his
fearful is impressive size and physical
strength the mountain is that's wrong
the his weapon of choice is the great
sword at most
men are not even able to sing with two
hands while he's throwing enough to
build it with one hand his friend gives
him a huge advantage in comets allowing
him to defeat far more skilled men he
wears armor larger and thicker than
other Knights would be able to wear
providing him a huge advantage against
his opponents at the other hand we have
his younger brother the Hound skilled
warrior who because of his already
mentioned older brother there's a
horrible facial scar on the right side
of its head which is a result of the
mountain nearly burning off half of his
face the mountain punished his younger
brother by holding his head into a
burning brazier which resulted with the
Hound being deeply afraid of fire and
with those two being enemies that were
sins centered the council gain is also
considered as one of the most skilled
and dangerous men in Westeros in the
first season we witnessed a fight
between those two brothers and we've
been waiting for the second cool game
Bowl ever since in that fight the Hound
was shown to be able to deal the
mountain evenly they exchanged a few
blows until King Robert ordered a halt
to the madness the mountain is
doubtlessly stronger than the Hound the
Lexx technical skill which fill in my
opinion be of the crucial points and
will eventually result with the Hound
finally killing his older brother
because of whom he bears the horrible
facial scar and he has a fear of fire
but also because of whom the Hound
steadfastly refused to be knighted or
take holy vows the Hound is jaded with
knighthood and has developed an extreme
content for romances and songs the
person Knights and worse is glorious
which is a result of his disgust at the
brutality of his older sibling which
instead of being punished resulted with
the mountain being rewarded with respect
and knighthood let me know your opinion
about who gamble and who do you think
will win in the comment section down
below a few people asked me in the
comment section whether or not it's
possible that sir gregor clegane can
only be killed by fire long sir short is
he white the mountain definitely is not
white since the knight King uses magic
to reanimate recently this is body in
order to act as his minion Oh Khyber
news science at knowledge he gained from
repugnant and unnatural experimentation
elimin people in order to save the
mountains life whites are reanimated
corpses raised from death by the walkers
while the mountain has only been saved
from the death by Qyburn and it's also
important to highlight that the whites
and the mountain do not share any trait
it's also important to say that the
whites are often described as slow and
clumsy and seem to function on more of a
zombie level of instinct well the same
cannot be said for the mountain
so yeah the mountain can be killed by
fire by sword by anything which would
cause the death to every other human in
my opinion the Hound will not kill the
mountain with his sword he will finally
overcome his fear of fire and burned
mountain to death this of course will
have the story of the game brothers come
full circle the mountain is the one who
burned hound so it would be a sort of
poetic justice to see a hound get his
vengeance by burning his brother I also
think the Hound will die after killing
his brother as I believe the mountain
will mortally wound the Hound before the
hound kills him at the end the most
important thing is that cool game ball
is a hypothetical battle between the
Hound that mountain is over hyped event
among Game of Thrones fans and is most
likely going down in the final season
let me know your opinion about all of
this in the comment section down below
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see you in the next one peace
[Music]